China's zero covered policy continues to
exert pressure on its people
the reports
of demonstrations that foxconn's biggest
plant in China people wielding sticks
smashing surveillance cameras and
windows at the massive Campus of the
Apple supplier tough restrictions put in
place at the plants to quash A covid-19
outbreak and this facility has been
under a variety of covered restrictions
for months and they have ended in the
rare instance of violence at the plant
in the Central City of zhangju the
unverified footage during the rounds on
social media is alarming
foreign
this is the Mega Factory in China That's
responsible for around 50 to 70 of all
the iPhones in the world its nickname is
iPhone City
[Music]
in late October a single covet case was
detected among the Foxconn staff and
according to the Chinese government's
zero covet policy that meant the entire
Factory had to go into lockdown most
Foxconn workers live in filthy dorms on
the factory grounds filthy conditions
garbage piling up in the hallway the
factory plunged into chaos videos showed
workers scrambling fighting to get
enough food and supplies and thanks to
the lockdown they were locked inside
these dorms with no pay and little food
they've been complaining online saying
that the conditions at the factory have
deteriorated that they're low on food as
well as medical supplies because they
live and work there and then also a lot
of the people have been quarantined
there
while other workers were taken away to
quarantine facilities in some of the
quarantine areas notices are hung up
that read don't approach as returning
Foxconn workers are in quarantine
[Music]
number third Foxconn dormitory look at
so many people wearing white and those
with suitcases they are the ones being
taken away for quarantined they were
living like forgotten prisoners no one
cared if they starved got sick or
couldn't contact their families life
became unbearable and after an entire
month of being locked down the dam
finally broke on November 23 2022.
[Applause]
foreign
ERS escaped and walked hundreds of miles
to their homes
[Music]
[Music]
others chose the fights it was a massive
Uprising something that China and apple
had never seen before
foreign
[Music]
but this is also happening at a pretty
critical time for Apple because it's
preparing to launch its new iPhone in
the next few months how much will this
disruption affect production so the
number is expected to be slashed by as
much as 30 even though Foxconn is trying
to shift the production to its uh Hub in
Shenzhen but we don't know how much that
can actually make up for it and with the
row out of Iphone 14 expected at the at
the end of the year towards the holiday
season this could eventually and
potentially have a lot of impact on the
global Supply and what did Apple CEO Tim
Cook had to say about all this chaos do
you have any reaction to the factory
workers that were beaten and detained
for protesting coveted lockdowns
foreign
do you regret restricting airdrop access
that protesters used to evade
surveillance from the Chinese government
single word stay dangerous and these are
the de facto slaves behind your iPhone
but really fast if you watch this
channel then you probably have big goals
you want to make more money but you
can't forget that you also have to
protect what you have especially online
I thought I was pretty good at being
safe online but when I signed up for the
app Aura and fill out some basic
information about myself or I had
discovered that my data had been leaked
on the dark web six times
this feature alone is worth signing up
for aura's 14 day free trial at aura.com
Jake and why I'm super excited to
partner with them because identity theft
is no joke someone gets their identity
stolen every 14 seconds and the average
cost to the victim is a thousand dollars
on top of all the time and stress you
waste on the ordeal which means in the
time I've been telling you about Aura
three of you might have had your
identity stolen and what I love about
Aura is that this is far from the only
feature they have typically to stay safe
online you have to pay for a bunch of
different cyber security apps but where
Aura is a One-Stop shop or monitors your
credit score they have a password
manager a VPN anti-virus software to
scan your computer and more all in one
affordable subscription like this recent
alert I got about how Aura automatically
asked one data broker to remove my
personal information so start protecting
yourself online now and get two weeks of
Aura completely for free by going to
aura.com Jake with the link below you
will be shocked at how much of your
private information or it finds exposed
over the next two weeks that's aura.com
Jake for 14 days free thanks to or for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Village in China and you need to feed
your family fast you've heard of this
employer called Foxconn a Taiwanese
company that is the biggest employer in
China and one of the biggest Employers
in the world and you heard about iPhone
City their biggest Factory where pretty
much everyone gets hired as long as they
have a valid ID and can recite the
English alphabets you hear that you will
spend your days living in a dorm with
seven other workers and that in the
mornings you'll walk over an hour to the
factory and 10 hours later you'll walk
another full hour back to your dorm you
hear that the work will be boring but at
least it will give you a decent stable
income at Foxconn Factory workers make
350 iPhones in minutes at one point
eighty five percent of the world Supply
came from this one building what started
as a small 10 person company that made
Atari joysticks in the 80s has now grown
into the single largest employer in
China 1.3 million people are on
foxconn's payroll that's the same number
of people who live in Estonia and it's
not just a factory it is a mini City
around the city you'll find restaurants
clothing stores movie theaters and bars
when you first set eyes on the place it
almost looks fun and not that bad but
what they don't tell you is that in
order to keep your job you'll have to
work overtime that's 12 hours a day
sometimes even 14 hours a day 7 days a
week doing the same monotonous task over
and over and over and over again a lot
of workers end up depressed if you make
a mistake your boss will force you to
write a formal apology and read it in
front of the entire staff you might be
asked to stand at attention for several
hours as punishments at the end of your
shift you'll go back to your dorm to
sleep and the next day you'll get up to
do it all over again and all of this for
Just Around 330 dollars a month which is
way below the around 1300 national
average
so in order to make more money you'll
have no choice but to sign up for
foxconn's Unwritten overtime role if
your boss asks you to pull a 12 hour
shift at the last minutes you say yes
otherwise they'll just replace you with
another body they have a constant line
of slaves I mean workers just outside
the factory doors waiting to take your
job and if they happen to be a little
short on applicants they'll just drop
off some people from a nearby Village or
recruit children from a nearby school
because there's never a shortage of
peasants that need a little extra cash
even if it kills them
foreign
[Music]
the world's largest contract
manufacturer for electronics and
Shenzhen which has been shaken by a
series of worker suicides a confused and
grieving family wondering how it could
have ended like this
[Applause]
in 2010 a Sunday string of suicides took
place on the Foxconn campus sandeno was
one of the first
sun was accused of stealing a prototype
model of the iPhone that I yet to be
released Sun told his friends that he
had been beaten and publicly humiliated
by the Foxconn security guards because
of this in a text to his girlfriend he
wrote quote dear I'm sorry go back home
tomorrow I ran into some problems don't
tell family don't contact me I'm begging
you for the first time please do it I'm
sorry End quotes
on the morning of July 16 2009 Sun
jumped from the 12th floor of his dorm
building more dust followed by the end
of 2011 18 employees had committed
suicide but why the sudden change
Foxconn workers have always lived
indoors hundreds of feet off the ground
their work was just as bad as it has
always been or was it
is
see this string of suicides lined up
perfectly with the growing popularity of
the iPhone Apple was putting in big
orders Foxconn management was getting
distracted by bigger problems and the
workers were being ignored while being
forced to work insane over time
these desks were not good for Apple so
they must have done something really big
to fix the problem right why yes they
did enter suicide Nets
it's a difficult situation they've got a
lot of workers who are leaving a very
poor rural areas coming to these
factories away from home for the first
time 19 years old
they're probably less prepared to leave
home than your typical high school
student going to college in this country
and
um
so I think there's some real issues
there and you all are bringing in
psychiatrists or anything we're trying
to understand right now okay before we
go in and say we know the solution we
need to understand what the problem is
so you have teams about what kind of
folks do you send over there I mean they
have to be some kind of social workers
or what do you send over there to find
out or just lawyers or what no not
lawyers not lawyers no definitely not
lawyers suicide nuts fatigue and boredom
are common in any Factory but this one
is surrounded by Suicide Nets they are
everywhere and if you think about it it
makes sense you can't fall to your death
if there's a net to catch you and
according to Steve Jobs suicides were
not that big of a deal anyways you know
they've had uh if you count the
attempted suicides 13 so far this year
and while that is still they have 400
000 people at this place so 13 out of
400 000 is 26 per year so far uh for 400
000 people or uh you know let's say
seven per 100 000 people that's still
under the U.S U.S suicide rate of 11 per
100 000 people but what Apple was soon
come to learn is that the thing about
suicide is if you really want to do it
you will find a way so as the years went
by Foxconn employees are at the Stage
Group suicides in 2012 150 workers
gathered on a rooftop and threatened the
jump if they weren't given their Fair
wages the same thing happened in 2016.
the group's War eventually talked down
no one actually jumped but this growing
suicide movement was a key turning point
in foxconn's history it was the initial
spark that would eventually Burn It to
the Ground
foreign
this is what the Foxconn plan looked
like on November 23 2022 and this is why
these workers they've been angry about
wages or angry about dirty living
conditions and chaotic covet rules it's
unbelievable this would happen inside
China this is a Foxconn worker who was
there he also claims thousands like him
didn't get sick when they were stuck in
quarantine with covin
[Music]
just one month earlier Foxconn was put
in a closed-loop lockdown which meant
that no one was allowed to leave the
Foxconn campus they were locked in until
every kova case was cleared workers were
promised pay if they went into
quarantine but they would soon come to
realize that that was all a lie new
hiresworth promised a bonus if they
worked during the outbreak some people
quit their jobs just to join Foxconn at
this time but guess what there was no
bonus that was a lie too at first we
sought to address the issue because we
didn't voluntarily go into quarantine
and then we wanted to ask whether
quarantine could be counted as working
days and then for the first Gathering we
just wanted to discuss these issues and
then we didn't know there might be some
people trying to make trouble
so as the situation developed we
assembled and then went down from the
dormitory to the Gathering and after it
became what it was the dorms were
unlivable they weren't getting paid they
weren't getting fed iPhone City had
become a giant prison and the workers as
inmates and the prisoners wanted outs
boscon eventually offered each employee
fourteen hundred dollars just so they
would stop destroying the factory but it
was too late for the first time it was
more than just about the money I left
because management was still fairly
chaotic and nothing they said ever
counted for anything
so things could change suddenly we spoke
out at night to fight for our rights
[Music]
as a result of this Uprising Foxconn
found herself having trouble getting
enough workers to operate the assembly
line the company reported that it was
short around a hundred thousand workers
at iPhone City a hundred thousand
workers and because of that Foxconn CEO
sent a letter to Xi Jinping a letter
that warned that if the Chinese
government didn't relax their zero covet
policy it would threaten China's bottom
line Weeks Later Xi Jinping actually
agreed and China started relaxing the
lockdowns and that ladies and gentlemen
is just how powerful Foxconn is not many
companies have the power to sway the
Chinese governments but the again not
many companies produce up to 40 of the
world's Electronics we're talking Xbox
PlayStation Nintendo kendo's Alexa's
Google pixels they're all produced by
Foxconn not many companies employ so
many Chinese citizens and not many
companies have such a direct impact on
China standing on the global stage so
when Foxconn speaks Xi Jinping listens
[Music]
foreign
why is Apple so comfortable having
pretty much slaves in their supply chain
the easy answer is profits which is true
but it's not the full story see apple
employs these de facto slaves not
because they want to but because they
have to Apple would literally be out of
business if they didn't see iPhone City
employs around 350 000 people since they
make around 50 to 70 of the world's
iPhones we can assume that there's
around 350 000 other workers elsewhere
making the other half of all the iPhones
so 700 000 workers in total but that is
just for the iPhone Apple also makes a
lot of other stuff like airpods MacBooks
iPads so let's bring that total work
account up to let's say double that at
1.4 million servants let's also assume
that these 1.4 million servants are all
getting paid around Thirty hundred
thirty dollars a month or around four
thousand dollars annually pretty cheap
right well not really because that's
already around half a billion dollars in
payroll half a billion dollars for de
facto slaves now let's say Tim Cook all
of a sudden sees the light and decides
that he wants to make a change he wants
to transition Apple away from this
unethical labor force and only employ
people in First World countries while
paying them a living wage which in
America MIT estimates to be around 69
000 per year but let's be real you're
Apple in America you will need to give
your workers a ton of benefits and stuff
so let's run the true cost per employee
to around a hundred thousand dollars as
following the estimate provided by the
U.S Small Business Association so we
went from paying around four thousand
dollars per year for each of your slaves
air quotes to paying a hundred thousand
dollars a year for each of your first
full employees well would you look at
that not using Financial slave labor
would increase your expenses by a
whopping 134 billion dollars Apple only
made around a hundred billion dollars in
net income as of July 2022 which means
if Apple took this at the goal routes
they would go from making a hundred
billion dollars a year to losing 30
billion dollars every single year in
other words they would be out of
business which means Apple's entire
business model is dependent on de facto
slave labor they can't live without it
and the scary thing is that it's not
just Apple run the same kind of logic on
most of the biggest corporations in the
world and you'll realize that they're
all dependent on de facto slave labor
none of them would have been able to
scale to how big they are today if it
wasn't for de facto slave labor and that
ladies and gentlemen is the secret of
the world slavery see it used to be that
you would need a standing army to
conquer a territory to enslave its
people with whiffs and chains like the
Roman Empire did but today slavery comes
in a much more sophisticated form it
comes in the form of debts of
Outsourcing of globalization and every
single powerful government and
Corporation have become Masters at this
game just like apple has
slavery never went away it just changed
forms and it slipped right underneath
our Consciousness and the elites have
worked very hard to keep it that way but
not anymore because once I realized all
this after years of researching these
videos I knew I had to expose all of it
so I compiled all my research into my
greatest body of work yets Financial
slavery Master Class 20 plus lessons all
narrated by me and the same addictive
documentary style format you've come to
love all centered around this
fundamental secret and how you can use
it to gain more wealth and power for
yourself there has never been a course
like this made I've spent the last six
months of my life working on this it's
why I haven't been voicing the videos
recently and you are gonna love it so
scroll down click the link below and
watch the first lesson for free right
now and I wanted this to be a chest for
you to make money right away too so on
top of all the life-changing knowledge
You're Gonna Learn you're also going to
be able to earn around a hundred dollars
for every person you refer to the master
class but that is not the special Parts
the special part is that just like
Andrew Tates Hustler's University
affiliate program where some Affiliates
were making uppers of eleven thousand
dollars a week just from posting clips
of Tates I also provide you with
step-by-step instructions just like Tate
did on how to take clips of my videos
edit them into tick tocks and YouTube
shorts so that you too can go viral and
get sales Tate only paid his Affiliates
25 per sign up but we're gonna pay you
four times that at around a hundred
dollars so scroll down and click the
link below and buy now
foreign
[Music]